There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
from August to test for ourselves.
These Chameleon Flakes
from Kaima Cosmetics
have been everywhere lately.
They're definitely a unique product,
because they're like
little shavings of pigment
that shift color.
I wanted to try these mixed with
the Glistening Pigment Mix,
which is how I saw it
being used all over TikTok,
but I could not get this to look good
no matter what I did --
adding more of the mix, using less,
mixing it for longer.
It honestly doesn't
look that bad on camera,
but nothing was making it look
like what I saw in so many videos.
I finally decided to use
it how it's recommended
on the product page:
just apply a thin layer
of glitter adhesive
and tap the flakes on,
and it worked amazingly.
These look so beautiful on the eyes,
they really do,
but they come with a
bit of a learning curve.
I am so into no-makeup makeup right now,
and I had to try out
L'Oréal's new tinted serum
with hyaluronic acid.
I'm usually very skeptical of products
that combine skin care and makeup,
but I'm a huge fan of this.
The coverage is light
but does a great job
of evening the skin out
and giving a very glowy, hydrated finish,
and it claims to smooth
your skin over time.
I don't know how true that is,
but if you're looking for
a great skin tint at the drugstore,
this is one of the best I've ever tried.
Coley Cosmetics is a new brand for me.
These eye-shadow bases
were all over social media,
and I was very intrigued
because I've never used
a colored base before.
So to see what the difference was,
I applied the base to just one eye
and then applied shadow to both eyes.
This shadow is super pigmented on its own,
but I could immediately see the difference
in the eye with the base versus without.
The color was more pigmented, vibrant,
it even felt more neon to me,
and I didn't use that much,
so I was super impressed with this.
Even the inner corner
on the eye with the base was brighter.
They sell every color you'll ever need,
and you get so much product for $14.
Next, I tried these little
cotton-swab lipsticks
from Fomomy.
You basically snap its neck,
and the lipstick inside the stick
drains to the bottom
end, and then you apply.
This ... worked.
I mean, I can't say that it didn't work.
The actual lipstick itself
feels like a very thin liquid.
Once it dries, it really doesn't budge,
and it lasted on me all day.
The color was definitely there,
but the stain looked patchy
because I had some dry patches on my lips.
I don't really see the point
in a product like this.
Maybe if you're always
on the go or something,
or if applying regular lipstick
has just gotten too boring for you,
but this seems like a lot of waste
for just an OK lip stain.
It was fun to snap them open, though.
And, finally, we have
an interesting product
from Pat McGrath, the
IntensifEyes Artistry Wand.
I was confused as to
what this was at first,
because it just looks like
a fancy $32 Chapstick,
but it's essentially a mixing liquid
in a convenient pen form
that intensifies eye shadow.
So I applied it to just one eye
to see what the difference would be.
To make things even more difficult,
I used a patchy eye shadow from E.l.f.
and also one of my dustiest,
crustiest shimmers.
This shimmer is literally four years old
and pretty dried out,
but I have to say that this stuff
did make these shadows look more vibrant
and surprisingly easy to blend
without getting patchy.
Look at how different these eyes look.
It mainly seems like one of those products
that's made for a makeup-artist kit
and not an everyday consumer.